human history is told by the energy we
use at first we had to use our muscles
then we learned to control fire
we industrialized the world using coal
and oil and entered the Atomic Age when
we learned how to split a nucleus at
each step we increased our energy
harvest to a scale never seen before and
advanced as a species currently we're
slowly transitioning to renewables and
if we're lucky fusion energy will become
viable in the future as humanity
progresses further if we don't destroy
ourselves or our habitat we will likely
gain complete control of our planet's
resources at that stage
we'll probably begin to look outwards
for new places to expand into but space
is hard and establishing a serious human
presence in the solar system will
require ungodly amounts of energy
luckily we know where to find it the Sun
the ultimate source of energy a furnace
100 quintillion times more powerful than
our most efficient nuclear reactor it
shines with the energy of a trillion
nuclear bombs per second so how do we
get this energy not some of it all of it
[Music]
if we want to collect the most energy
physically possible we'll have to build
the largest most ambitious structure in
the universe the Dyson Sphere a mega
structure that encompasses a whole star
to capture its power output for an
intelligent species building a Dyson
Sphere is a technological leap on a par
with the discovery of fire for our
ancestors the transition from a
planetary species to an interstellar
species it would usher in an age of
exploration and expansion on a scale we
can barely imagine so what would it look
like a solid shell enveloping the Sun is
probably not the way to go a large rigid
body like that would be vulnerable to
impacts possibly shattering it would be
liable to drift and could crash straight
into the Sun a more viable design for a
Dyson Sphere might be a Dyson swarm an
enormous set of orbiting panels that
collect the sun's power and beam it
elsewhere such as sward would give
humanity basically unlimited energy but
building it won't be easy
the Sun is very big so we need a lot of
satellites
if each satellite is a square kilometer
we'd need around 30 quadrillion to
surround the Sun even if they're built
as lightly as possible we need about 100
quintillion tons of material and then we
need the energy to actually put the
parts together and deliver them to their
positions around the Sun on top of all
that we need to have a permanent
infrastructure set up in space to start
building let's assume for the purposes
of this video that our descendants will
take care of that and want to create the
mega structure we can sort the
challenges into three main categories
materials design and energy to get the
vast amounts of raw materials required
for our Dyson swarm will have to largely
disassemble a whole planet
of the planets available mercury is the
best candidate it's the closest to the
Sun and very metal-rich close to the Sun
also means less moving stuff around and
mercury has no atmosphere and only about
a third of the surface gravity of Earth
making it comparatively easy to launch
material into space next we should
consider the design of our swarm simpler
is better conventional solar panels are
far too intricate and short lives our
satellites need to operate without
repairs or intervention for
astronomically long times and they need
to be cheap to produce but they're most
likely going to be enormous mirrors
which refocus sunlight to central
collecting stations like in concentrated
solar power on earth to build and launch
them efficiently they must be incredibly
light made of little more than polished
metal full bound to some supports and
last we need the energy to build and
launch the swarm itself taking a part of
planets and launching things into space
requires an enormous amount of energy
for example if we used all the fossil
fuels and uranium on earth and we were
perfectly efficient we could only launch
as much mass as Mount Everest into space
a rather meager accomplishment compared
to planetary disassembly to get the
energy needed to build a Dyson Sphere
it's almost as if you're going to need
the power output of a dyson sphere but
that's ok there's plenty of sunlight to
be had on Mercury so let's get to work
humans are expensive to keep alive and
are very sensitive to the environment so
we'd want to automate as much as
possible ideally we'd have a small crew
of controllers who oversee an army of
autonomous machines doing the actual
work there are four major pieces of
technology required solar collectors
miners refiners and launch equipment the
solar collectors are going to give us
the energy we need to disassemble the
planet to start maybe we deploy
something like one square kilometer of
them either as mirrors or as traditional
solar panels
they'll provide the energy to run our
miners which strip-mine the surface of
the planet and our refiners which
extract valuable elements and fabricate
them into our swarm satellites to get
them into space we need a creative and
efficient solution rockets aren't too
expensive and difficult to deorbit and
reuse instead we'll want to use a sort
of railgun a longer electromagnetic
track which launches our satellites at
high speeds
our swarm satellites will be packed
tight for launch unfurling like an
enormous origami once in orbit from this
point we can take advantage of
exponential growth using the energy of
the existing parts of the swarm to build
more infrastructure on Mercury and
launch new panels faster and faster each
panel provides the energy to build
another those to work together to build
the next to four become eight eight
become 16 and so on within just about 60
doubling times the Sun would be
completely surrounded by solar panels
and this can happen quickly if a square
kilometer of solar collectors takes a
month to build we could be done in a
decade if only our infrastructure on the
planet's surface can keep up with the
quickly growing budget of energy even
collecting 1% of the sun's energy is an
unbelievable change in our species
energy budget we could create the
infrastructure to being basically
unlimited amounts of energy around the
solar system for all sorts of projects
colonies on other worlds terraforming
planets constructing more mega
structures or even traveling to other
stars it could be the start of an
interstellar civilization based on
physics alone this is not just possible
but easy it's such a simple process and
such a necessary step for any species to
expand beyond their home planet that
many astronomers think there are
probably Dyson spheres already out there
in the Milky Way
we haven't spotted any yet but they
could be there
it's far from certain that humanity will
ever get to this point our attention is
too often focused on short-term
political gains and conflicts that will
not matter in the long run but if we
survive the challenges we've set
ourselves we could potentially become
the first species in the universe to
create a structure with the scope of a
star if we do it the only limitation
left will be our own imagination we've
just hit you with a lot of pretty wild
claims and crazy concepts if you're like
us and enjoy using the power of science
to determine absurd ways to destroy
stuff you might want to hear how you can
come up with something like that
yourself brilliant is a problem-solving
website that helps you learn stuff
through fun puzzles that split up a
complex problem into bite-sized chunks
and build up to an interesting
conclusion it helps you understand how
science works by actually using it
instead of just memorizing a bunch of
stuff brilliance has tons of interesting
courses and puzzles on things like
quantum computing astronomy and logic
and even dyson sphere's
if you visit brilliant org slash
nutshell or click the link in the
description you can sign up for free and
learn all kinds of things as a bonus for
cooks without viewers the first 688
people will also get 20% off their
annual membership with brilliance you
can finish each stay a little bit
smarter and just maybe you can help to
expand the human species into the
universe one day we love dyson sphere's
so much that we've also made a poster
about them it will look pretty on your
wall but also has some information about
the concept of a Dyson Sphere a great
way to start a conversation or you can
just stare at it and dream about the
future go get it here
[Music]